bien je suis en provençal je suis du sud
je suis d'une région qui est métissé qui
a su accueillir énormément de population
mais maintenant nous pouvons dire que
cela suffit parce que notre territoire
ne peut plus accueillir les populations
que nous accueillons dans les conditions
que nous les accueillons nous voudrions
haut niveau cette europe mettre des
frontières et défend des frontières de
l'europe
nous voudrions aussi décider des visas
que nous accordons et l'aide au
développement que nous accordons aux
pays en voie de développement mais nous
voulons aussi refusé tout élargissement
de l'europe parce que cet élargissement
de l'europe c'est plus d'europe
mais c'est pas mieux d'europe nous
voulons une europe qui protège et nous
voulons donc réellement et nous dans le
sud nous en sommes d'autant plus
convaincu refusé et le dire clairement
refusé l'entrée de la turquie dans cette
union européenne la turquie tant qu'elle
ne reconnaît pas le premier génocide du
xxème siècle ce n'est pas un état avec
qui nous pouvons discuter dans l'union
européenne
donc nous voulons pas une europe qui
s'ouvre à tout le monde
nous voulons une europe protéger